Wh Auden,
western [inaudible].
Uh,
there really is no more dramatic,
uh,
a contrast in this course, I think, uh,
then then to go from late
Stephens to early on,
uh,
in
Stephens is a boring Oh, uh, Oh,
20 years before. Um, uh, uh,
I'm, um, goes on writing,
uh, to his death in 1973. Uh,
so his career is somewhat
later, uh, then Stevens,
but again, uh, we're doing something a
little complicated. We're moving from, uh,
Stevens, his poems of
the late, uh, excuse me,
late 1940 [inaudible] early 1950s now to,
uh,
odd and, uh, and his early career, uh,
including poems are written in
the very late 1920s in the 1930s.
And we'll, we'll get up to, uh, uh,
the start of World War
Two by the end of class.
Uh,
so in one sense we're going back
in time back in literary history,
back and a cultural history,
uh, moving from the 1950s,
from, uh, this postwar
moment in which, uh,
Steven's is riding his late palms to,
uh,
an earlier phase. Uh,
at the same time, uh,
we are also, however, moving forward
in a sense in literary history,
uh, moving forward, uh,
to a, a poetry that, uh,
is distinctly, uh, and, uh,
very asley a poetry that
comes after modernism.
Uh, and, and to that extent that we
could think of as post modernist, uh,
it is, uh, well what do we
mean by that and what do,
what do I mean,
uh,
with Stevens in mind,
there are no giants and Auden,
uh,
their, uh, everything is a life size. Uh,
poems don't take the place of mountains.
Uh,
rather they,
you could say take place among them.
And in mountains figure,
interestingly in, uh, uh,
Auden's poetry and a number of places,
uh,
in Arden, there is no new
knowledge of reality to be had.
Uh,
in fact,
there's only a old wisdom
that nobody wants to face.
The, the modernism turns
on a kind of, uh, access,
uh, you could say a modernism
as wasteland or as bridge,
uh, uh, state of cultural decay in crisis,
or if promise, uh, and,
uh, celebration, uh,
pound Eliot on one side,
a crane,
Stevens on the other well
oddness beyond these debates,
they don't matter much
to him. Uh, he is, uh,
in a sense beyond, uh, the nostalgia of,
of the one side. And he's also, uh, quite,
uh, uh, self consciously beyond, uh,
the romantic exaltation of the other,
uh,
on, uh, is, uh, uh,
a British poet.
Uh,
he writes out of the distinctly
British tradition a tradition in which,
uh,
well tradition itself is in
a sense taken for granted.
It's something that they're accessible,
uh,
part of the poets,
repertoire that needed to be
either struggle for or against,
uh, industrial capitalism. Hart Crane is,
is all excited about this stuff.
Uh,
it's an old thing in the
north of England. Um, uh,
and, and, uh, Auden's
early poems take place in,
in a, um, a landscape of, uh, uh,
now, uh, fading, uh, and century old,
uh, industry, uh, early on.
Uh, later on. Um,
these are our, our,
uh, characters, uh, uh,
as well that are important to
the history of ans reception.
There's been a tendency to see his
career is coming in to have a divided by,
uh, his immigration, uh,
to, um, the United States.
Uh, and, uh, uh, the very end of 1938,
um, uh, a British Auden and then, uh,
in American on, uh, both Auden's,
uh,
you could say have a distinct characters.
Uh, early on, early on, uh, a,
a poet, a born in the city of York, uh,
the son of a doctor,
uh,
interested in natural science, uh,
and in scientific ways of knowing,
uh, a poet for whom science,
uh, was not an enemy,
but rather a kind of tool,
uh,
a point of view or perspective,
expressed importantly, uh,
for a, uh, early on in, uh,
uh, the work of Freud,
but also the work of Marx.
Uh,
the early on is,
is not an Orthodox Marxist and
certainly not a communist party member.
Uh, but Marxism is important to
him. Uh, it's part of a worldview.
Uh, it's worked into his
sense of the world as a, uh,
seen, uh, where social classes
compete and struggle with each other.
Uh, and where the important
choices to be made are, uh, uh,
moral ones. Um, uh, moral ones that, uh,
enter into our political choices.
Uh,
it's also, uh, a, uh, uh,
uh,
the case in Auden's early poetry that,
um,
that he tends to conceive of the
world and a kind of us and them, uh,
construction. Uh, there's a,
a sense in the early poems
of, uh, extreme privacy, uh,
and the privacy of address, uh, the
way in which the poet speaks to us.
Uh, the way in which he
conceives his point of view. Um,
these early poems conceive a kind of,
uh,
you could say cooter re
audience, uh, who are, um,
uh, um, Auden's, uh, intellectual,
a leftist, a largely gay friends, uh,
at Oxford where he's, uh, uh,
riding his earliest poems.
Uh,
homosexuality is an important
context, uh, for, um,
uh, this early Odden and, and, uh,
his ways of imagining himself
and talking to us, uh, uh,
Auden's, um, uh,
odd and comes with a kind
of a embattled, uh, uh,
necessarily secretive,
uh, and, and, uh, uh,
self protective, uh, investment in,
in intimate relationships. There
there's something that have to be, uh,
fought for, um, um, they are prized,
uh, and they, um, uh, uh,
are something that must be
protected, uh, from, um,
the intrusions of, uh, other hostile, uh,
or disapproving eyes.
Um,
uh,
yeah. Well, let's, let's
look at an early poem here.
Uh, this is, um, uh,
in your, um, all right. Yes.
Packet.
Okay.
From the very first coming down,
it's, it's, uh, called, uh,
I'll, uh, I'll, I'll show you some,
some photos first before
getting into poem. This is, uh,
this is one I like a of the Oxford Auden.
Um,
uh, a, a sensitive boy, uh,
with the, uh, um, um,
interesting legend that he has,
uh, uh, applied to himself here.
Probably in retrospect, the
cerebral life would pay. He said
it was going to be a, he was going to
make it work to be an intellectual. Um,
this is, uh, another
one, uh, uh, on, uh, the,
the, the rakish a young on, uh, uh,
this one also with, um, a, a,
a kind of a legend on top, uh, uh,
you know, Adam's hand where he
calls himself Utopian youth,
grown old Italian, uh, as in fact,
this was a certain kind of trajectory.
He would live, uh, starting,
uh, as a kind of Utopian youth.
And then, you know, later, uh,
learning how to relax and
have a good time in Italy. Um,
the, uh, uh, let's see here.
Yeah, I want to, um,
great. I've got my slides somewhat
backwards. So this is, um, uh,
Auden's poems. His first book, uh,
I believe it's 1930.
Uh,
they're written in a while.
He's a student at Oxford and,
uh,
um, excuse me, um, includes, uh,
poems that are this one that
I'll discuss in a moment,
but it's worth throwing them on the page.
Uh, they're laid out without titles.
Again, I'm somewhat as, um, uh,
Williams. His early poems are
presented. Uh, they are, um,
uh,
sat here almost sort of secretively,
I'd like to say without that, um,
public introduction of a title,
uh,
and well as I am suggesting of
some degree of self protection and,
um, a reticence are, uh,
important qualities and in fact,
themes of this early poetry.
Uh,
let, let's take a look at this poem
that, uh, I've got up on the, uh, screen,
uh, right now, uh, which is, uh,
called from the very first coming down.
Uh, that's the first line of
the poem and it's, um, uh,
generally known that way.
Um,
from the very first coming down into a
new valley with a frown already we're,
we're listening to a polity
rhymes, uh, because of the sun.
And the last way you certainly remain,
uh, there's a, you hear there's an
eye, the palm is a kind of letter. Uh,
and in fact, a kind of love letter. Uh,
today I crouching behind the sheep pen
and this is that northern landscape that,
that uh, uh, Auden comes from.
A I crouching behind a sheep pen,
heard travel across a sudden
bird cry out against the storm.
And found the years Arca Completed
Round and loves Warren Circuit.
Re begun endless with no
dissenting turn shall see,
shall pass as we have seen the swallow
on the tile springs green preliminary
shiver past a solitary truck,
the last shunting in the autumn.
And so on.
Your letter comes speaking
is you speaking of much,
but not to come. The letter
comes, uh, in a sense,
uh, from an intimate of
friend, perhaps a lover, uh,
uh, saying much in yet, uh,
were given no content to it.
Uh, it's a veiled in that
sense, uh, it speaking of much,
but much that is not to come.
It seems,
uh,
it,
it's very content and
promises it seems withheld.
Uh,
then there's this further stanza
nor speech is close nor fingers numb
if love not seldom has received
an unjust answer was deceived.
This, this early on is, is,
has this highly compressed syntax,
uh,
that requires you to kind of put the
sentences together and fill in parts that
seemed to have been, uh,
occluded, uh, in the poets, uh,
compressing a of language.
Um, again, uh, uh,
an almost veiled form of speech.
Uh,
odd and says I decent with the seasons
move different or with a different love
is a sense that the love that he,
that animates him is a different love.
It sets him apart nor he doesn't
question over much the nod,
the stone smile of this country.
God that never was more reticent,
always afraid to say more than it meant.
Uh, there's an intimacy that
the poem establishes here, uh,
with the you, uh, and with
us as readers, um, that,
uh,
suggests a kind of implied
shared knowledge that the
poem nonetheless does not
openly declare a and doesn't specify,
but rather remains reticent about.
And we're invited into that reticence,
uh,
as well as the poets scruple,
expressed here as,
uh,
the wisdom of that country,
God,
which it's hard to know exactly how
we're supposed to interpret that,
whether that's, uh, uh,
actual figure or a kind of a
stone in the landscape that,
that the poet is animating in this
way. But in any case, seeing that,
that figure that country God as
emblematic of a, uh, a reticence, uh,
that scruples,
not to say more than it meant,
uh, in other words,
uh, there's, well, you,
you could compare this to Marianne
Moore's investment in restraint,
a very closely related,
uh, uh, in, in its,
um, moral, uh, valence
is, um, the idea here,
uh, is, is one that's
crucial in Ogden, uh,
throughout his career.
Uh,
that is the poet wishes to master
his intentions as a speaker.
He does not wish to
say more than he means,
and he means to say what he means,
uh,
and to insist on, um, uh,
meaning what he says. This is, uh,
this is a long way from,
its very different from
Wallace Stevens is a lavish,
uh, forms of play. His,
uh, uh, interest in,
um, uh, in exactness, uh, or, uh, uh,
poems that might resist the
intelligence almost successfully.
Uh,
odd wants very much to say what he means.
And he wants us to, uh, be
able to, to grasp that, um,
this, uh, uh,
well on conceives of poetry and of
language generally as a sphere of moral
action, uh, in which
truth is always at stake.
Uh, where, uh, the poet specific, uh,
office is to control and use
language in a kind of a responsible,
uh, and, uh, honest way. Um,
this is a poet wants to be honest.
Uh,
poets have not always wished
this. Uh, uh, you can,
you can think about Hart Crane,
uh, saying, uh, sleep, death,
desire, hasten while they
are true. Uh, in other words,
a crane's, uh, investment, uh,
willing investment in what
he recognizes as a illusion,
uh, or, or, um, you know,
a kind of temporary truth.
Uh, Arden is a rather, uh, uh,
morally bound to a
responsible for what he says.
Uh, he's concerned, uh, in this sense, uh,
with the limits of poetry, uh, with, uh,
saying only what's meant.
Um,
again, uh, a connection should
be drawn to a Marion Moore who,
who share something with
a odd in this way. Uh,
you remember her long
poem, um, uh, poetry. Uh,
I too dislike it. Uh, uh,
there must be something important
beyond all this fiddle. Uh, and yet, uh,
you know, after reading it
with a con perfect content
for it, when discovers, uh,
nonetheless, uh, a place for
the genuine, uh, she says,
or something very close to that. Um,
well that's the beginning in, um, uh,
Maura's case, uh, of a very
long, uh, an extravagant poem,
which over the course of her career,
uh, as she returned to it, uh,
and sought to tell the truth
in her poem and, and, uh, to,
uh, insist on a what was
genuine, uh, she eventually, uh,
cut, uh, to only those
lines, uh, more, uh,
was as a poet, a rigorous, uh,
self reviser, um, who,
um, you know, cuts out,
uh, pieces, uh,
of her poems who cuts out individual
poems from her body of work. Uh,
so was Aaden Aaden,
uh, uh, importantly, um, uh,
revised his poems, uh, sometimes, uh,
uh, on multiple occasions,
uh, uh, always, uh,
as, uh, he collected them and
return to them in later, uh, uh,
volumes. There are a
couple important, um, uh,
examples of this, uh, including
the pumps, Spain, uh, on, uh, page 791,
um, uh, a poem that Auden wrote,
uh,
in response to, uh, the
Anti Fascist struggle, uh,
in the Spanish civil war, uh,
which he participated in a,
and it is, uh, a, uh, uh, a,
a poem that,
um,
Complex Lee, uh, and yet nonetheless, uh,
strongly, uh, comes to affirm the, um,
uh, uh, priority of, uh, making, um,
um,
political commitments over a and above,
uh, it appears, um, uh,
individual moral
discriminations, uh, and, uh,
other, uh, forms of, um, uh,
individual commitment.
Uh,
and there are ideas expressed in this,
a poem that became an anthem and one
of, uh, Auden's most, most famous,
uh, uh, poems of the 30s. Uh, well,
let me give you just a few
lines from it. Uh, and, um, uh,
page seven,
93,
um,
uh,
stirring us to March, uh, uh, odd, uh,
says, uh, tomorrow, perhaps
the future, uh, tomorrow,
the rediscovery of Romantic love, uh, uh,
uh, and so on. But today,
okay.
On Line 93, the deliberate
increase in the chances of death,
even the conscious acceptance of
guilt in the necessary murder.
Today,
the expanding of powers on the flat of
femoral pamphlet and the boring meeting
he's calling us to do the work
of revolution and postpone, um,
uh, as a goal, uh,
the rediscovery of a romantic
love and other Utopian projects,
uh, Auden would, would come to, uh,
find the morality of this
poem, um, objectionable, uh,
and uh,
uh,
to repudiate the notion that we should
ever accept a guilt in the necessary
murder, uh, that rather any
murder would be necessary, uh,
in order to advance a cause and,
uh, expressing his own self.
Censure cut the palm out of his, his
work. And if you buy Auden's collected,
uh, poems edited by as
executor a Edward Mendelson,
you will find that this
poem is not in there. Uh,
there are other, uh,
examples. Um, I'll, um,
uh, of of dramatic self revision. Uh,
let me just point to one
more, uh, that is famous, um,
in the pumps. September 1st, 1939, again,
one of Auden's most celebrated
and circulated poems.
Uh, he, uh, has, uh,
in, uh, the next to last stanza, uh,
these,
um,
assertions on page eight oh three.
All I have,
this is a poem occasion by the beginning
of the Second World War, uh, it,
um, positions the poet, uh, in a
dive, uh, in Manhattan drinking,
uh, with others. Uh,
he's reflecting on, um,
the European catastrophe now underway.
He says,
all I have is a voice
to undo the folded lie,
the romantic lie in the brain of the
sensual man in the street and the lie of
authority whose buildings grope the sky.
There is no such thing as the state,
and no one exists alone.
Hunger allows no choice to
the citizen or the police.
We must love one another. We're die, uh,
as, uh, uh, you are note below. Uh,
uh, registers a on a later
attempted to revise this line,
which struck him as,
uh,
in fact he called it incurably dishonest,
and, uh, uh, he, he revised
it a first with what, uh,
seem to him, uh, a, a more truthful claim.
We must love one another and die because
we're going to have to die in any case.
Uh, and that, uh, uh, eventually, uh,
he gave up on altogether, uh, and cut, uh,
the entire stands. Uh, uh, these, uh,
are examples of Auden a applying
a kind of stringent moral,
a self examination to the
language that he uses a in.
It's, uh, uh, um, a crucial part,
not only of the history of his work
and other, it's what he did with it,
but what of course we use doing in it,
uh, which was, uh, attempting to speak,
uh, in a truthful way, uh,
that he could take
responsibility for, uh, and yet,
which led him repeatedly to, um, uh,
forms of rhetoric that he would
mistrust, uh, and later, uh,
abandoned.
Uh,
all of this is consistent with the ways
in which Auden reconceived the modern
poets role.
Auden writes against Vat,
heck,
romantic inspiration. Uh, he, uh,
sees the modern poet as a
kind of rationalist, uh,
a rationalist,
especially skilled in the techniques
of poetry of language use,
uh, as expressed, uh, specifically, uh,
in technical mastery of
verse form and Genre.
Auden, uh, um, uh,
reclaims a following pound
Anglo Saxon alliterative meter.
Uh, he, uh,
rights in popular ballad forms,
all kinds of song forms,
many kinds of rhyme and meter.
Uh,
he, he takes over, uh,
you could say, uh, uh, uh,
song forms from the British music call,
which is something like Vaudeville. Uh,
he, um, produces intricate
stands, AIC patterns,
um, that we might find in
metaphysical poetry. He,
he produces ornate syllabic poems,
not unlike Marianne Moore's.
Sometimes he, uh, uh, influentially,
uh, revives the province Saul
forms of the Cistina, uh,
and the Kenzo Ne. Uh, and
other, uh, um, troubadour
a forms. Uh, if, uh, uh,
your,
your poetry writing teachers have made
you write sestinas you have odd and to
thank for this, uh, as
well as much else. Um,
there is,
uh,
in these various acts of appropriation
and reclaiming of averse forms,
a kind of, um, no nostalgia, uh, rather,
uh, there's a sense that all of
these forms are simply available.
They should be part of a poet's
tool kit. Uh, and, and this is,
I'm also part of, uh, what is,
um, well Auden's, uh, presentation
of himself as a kind of expert, uh,
as a poet with expertise,
with expertise in the language.
And all of this is part of,
in his early poetry,
what you would have to call
his precocious adultness. Uh,
his knowingness, uh, which is again,
connected to his will to tell the truth,
uh,
uh, uh, to tell the truth
unclouded by sentiment. Uh, the,
the, uh, the early on and the odd
that we see in those photographs,
he's remarkably cool, uh, in all senses.
Uh, this is a cool poet. Uh, uh,
James Merrill, a poet, um, uh,
who was a friend of Arden's, uh, and,
and, uh, uh, influenced by him and,
and, uh, many ways once
remarked, uh, that, um,
all of the Auden's poems were written
on paper on which the tears had dried.
Uh, and, uh, that's an evocative
idea. Uh, it's important,
first of all, uh, that yes,
those tiers have dried. Uh,
but it's also important that there
were tears, uh, and both of these, uh,
our,
our properties of,
of the palms and they make on
a special kind of love poet.
Uh, let's look at, uh, the early palm. Uh,
this lunar beauty,
uh,
which is, uh, on seven 87,
yeah,
this lunar beauty has no
history is complete in early.
If beauty later bear any feature,
it had a lover and is another,
this like a dream,
this love that I experienced and
right up and out of keeps other time.
It's lunar and day time is the
loss of this for time is inches.
And the heart's changes where
ghost has haunted, lost and wanted.
Yeah,
but this was never a ghost
endeavor nor finished.
This was ghosted ease until it passed.
Love shall not near the sweetness here.
North sorrow take his endless look.
Uh, contrast this poem, uh,
two closely related palm
heart cranes voyages,
uh, palm of extravagant, uh, rhetoric. Uh,
here. Uh, uh, Arden is not writing.
I ambig pentameter. He's writing.
What is the meter here? Demeter,
uh,
there are two beats line.
You can't have a line that's much
shorter and have it be align or a meter.
Uh, it, it's really the
innocence, the smallest, uh,
measure can a meter can sustain.
There is in the poem a kind
of formal rhetoric reticence,
uh,
and what is proclaimed as endless
here is not love but sorrow.
A sorrows look, uh, and,
and sorrow is personified.
They're in the position of the poet,
uh,
looking at the beloved already in a sense,
looking back at him,
uh,
a lunar beauty.
Let's turn a few pages forward
to seven 90 and read another,
uh, of Auden's love poms, um,
closely related.
Lay your sleeping head.
My love human on my faithless arm.
Time and fevers burn away.
Individual beauty from thoughtful
children and the grave proves the child of
femoral.
But in my arms till break of day,
let the living creature lie mortal guilty.
But to me the entirely beautiful
certainty fidelity on the
stroke of midnight pass.
Okay.
They always do.
There were bound to like vibrations
of a bell and fashionable.
Madmen raised their pedantic boring cry.
Every farthing of the cost.
All the dreaded cards foretell
shall be paid. But from this night,
not a whisper, not a thought, not a kiss,
nor look,
be lost.
You're going to have to pay for it.
But here it is and it is now.
And to be celebrated,
beauty,
midnight vision dies.
Let the winds of dawn that blow softly
round you're dreaming head such a day of
sweetness, show I am
knocking heart, may bless.
Find the mortal world enough.
Nunes of dryness.
See you fed by the involuntary powers.
Knights of insult,
let you pass watched by every human love
here again,
love is seen in the secularizing light
of certain future betrayal and loss.
Uh, to be living here is
to be mortal and guilty.
Uh,
to love is to be sure that
you will be faithless,
uh, that is to love fully, fully, uh,
and so to know love and beauty
entirely and in their entirety is,
uh,
to know them in the knowledge of time,
to know precisely that loves passing,
uh,
time here is not so much a kind
of emblem of human inconstancy,
uh, but rather have something
like natural law, uh,
to which everyone is subject.
Uh,
this is the theme of the,
uh,
very great poem written in
the popular ballot form,
uh, with, uh,
this title and Odense collected palms
as I walked out one evening on seven 93.
Uh,
yeah,
as I walked out one evening
walking down Bristol Street,
the crowds upon the pavement,
we're fields of harvest week and
down by the [inaudible] River,
I heard a lover sing under
an arch of the railway.
And here is his song.
Love has no ending.
I'll love you dear.
I love you till China and Africa meat
and the river jumps over the mountain and
salmon singing the street.
I'll love you til the ocean
is folded and hung up to dry.
And the seven stars go squawking
like geese about the sky.
The year she'll run like
rabbits free in my arms.
I hold the flower of the ages
and the first love of the world.
Okay,
have you ever said that?
And someone said that to you.
Okay.
But all the clocks in the city
began to were in time and they say,
oh,
let not time to see view.
You cannot conquer time in
the boroughs of the nightmare.
We're justice.
Naked is time.
Watches from the window and
coughs when you would kiss
in headaches and,
and worry vaguely.
Life leaks away and time.
We'll have his fancy
tomorrow or today into many.
A Green Valley drifts.
The appalling snow time breaks the
threaded dances and the divers.
Brilliant bow. Oh, plunge
your hands in water.
Plunge them in up to the wrist.
Stare,
stare in the base and in
wonder what you've missed.
The glacier knocks in the cupboard,
the desert size and the bed and the
crack and the tea cup opens a lane to the
land of the dead where the beggars raffle,
the bank notes and the giant
isn't chanting to Jack.
And the lily white boy is a roar
and Jill goes down on our back,
oh, look, look in the mirror.
Go look in your distress.
Life remains a blessing.
Although you cannot bless,
oh,
stand,
stand at the window as
the tiers scald and start.
You shall love your crooked
neighbor with your crooked heart.
It was late, late in the evening.
The lovers, they were gone.
The clocks had ceased.
Their timing and the deep river ran on
a, this is a ballad, uh,
on choice of it suggests, uh, uh,
that the song form is conveying
popular common wisdom.
Something we all know.
Uh,
it's expressing truth as a kind of
commonplace, uh, that is shared.
Like the tune itself.
Uh,
truth is not an elite knowledge.
It's something that's out there,
uh,
in the street and it touches
all of us, uh, in common.
Uh, there are here in the palm, um,
two distinct voices in quotation marks,
first the lovers,
and then the voice of time of the clocks,
uh,
the lover. When he speaks. Well,
the poem seems to say seems
to acknowledge he's lying
even if he doesn't know it or mean it.
And yet the poem still allows
him his truth, his say,
uh,
what it does really is it framed his
truth with this other larger truth,
which is times truth uttered by the
clocks and the clocks speak from the point
of view of disenchantment.
The lover cannot wash his hands.
Uh,
uh,
the palm gives us a kind of
image of primary sinfulness.
Again, how different
from Steven's, uh, uh,
ordinary life here is,
uh,
haunted by disrupted by elemental forces.
Uh,
the glacier knocks in the cupboard.
The domestic includes tragic
and uncanny dimensions.
Uh, they return like repressed
parts of the psyche in the palm,
uh, and still, uh,
there is a kind of constellation in view
in that ambiguous promise or command
that you and I will love each other are,
are crooked hearts will meet.
Uh,
there's a sense in which people are
bound to each other precisely, uh,
by the circumstances that
the poem describes in,
by the crookedness of their hearts,
uh, at the end. Then, uh, the
lovers and the clocks are all gone,
both, uh, and the river runs on.
There's that last stanza,
uh,
poetry in Auden,
speaks on behalf of a necessity,
a necessity that frames what we do and
think a necessity that determines the
circumstances within which
we make our moral choices.
Uh, in this way. Auden
like bishop who will,
will read next week, uh, is a poet,
a constantly drawing our attention
to matters of perspective,
uh, how things are seeing
how things are framed,
what the context of any given, uh, uh,
point of view, uh, or
utterance or action is, uh,
what is true and what is right from one
point of view may not be from another.
And this is,
this is part of the principle by
which often comes to in fact revise,
uh, and, uh, make, uh,
decisions about his,
his own work. Uh, that involves
censoring, um, his, uh,
uh, his, uh, his own language. Uh, the,
the great poem, uh, about this,
uh, theme, uh, that is, uh,
the,
uh,
way in which our knowledge and action
is a determined and bounded by the
perspectives, uh, uh, in which it
is viewed in which it takes place.
The great poem on this theme
is a music day. Bows are, um,
is, uh, also a poem that
we'll have to, um, uh,
wait to talk about it until
Monday when we will, uh,
talk about it,
uh,
in connection with the
almost contemporaneous
poem in memory of WB Yeats.